and shrine Ephraim humming at this ride
2015 three years in the Hall of Fame
Pittsburgh Steeler great Jerome Bettis
how are you JP the thunder from the sky
oh the other one it is burning it's okay
I thought he was just gonna leave after
that my drop but no this is that moment
where I get a chance to to bang on my
friend
a Michigan alum we have a very
long-standing very long-standing feud as
we do this we do it and we are back
online just as if we were a Wi-Fi yes we
are situations you need to take you to
event next or banging on the windows I'm
not we go before you go what was it like
in that room
it was electric in the room obviously
it's lunch you know all this all of
famers old it's all it's Hall of Famers
only but obviously you know
acknowledging the class but but also you
know speaking about you know tio in the
room it was it was an amazing time and I
was just so so blessed to be in there
but then you got a chance to hear from
different guys you know Dick Butkus he
gotta change what'd he say can you tell
me just tojust talked about the
linebackers and you know being proud
Louis and being proud of the linebackers
that position right and to see how they
played the game so so it was just it was
really neat to get to see guys speak
and do that well I don't want to get
these guys upset they're there they're
gonna take you idea what I had to do you
know seven minutes you know I want to
make sure no where are you going yeah
I've got to do it a bit for ei okay so
Jerome Bettis is the one bringing
Kaepernick's name back to the good
people whose character I'm bringing a
win for nor today this fall that's right
is this your own Paris everybody thanks
Jerome Jerome Bettis puts the microphone
down the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience